so many of us know the fugitive you know
the 90s movie the show from the 60s why
do you think viewers are really going to
connect to this new version of the
peaches
well i think of this one as kind of the
post-9 11 version of the fugitive
uh terrorism
has hit u.s soil technology has grown
leaps and bounds to the degree where
there's cameras and video
on every street corner in any major city
in the u.s
that can all be manipulated and it is in
this show i want film from every camera
within a 10 block radius so we could be
looking for anyone from anywhere
right there boyd what was the the whole
atmosphere like on set like does it feel
as intense as it is for us watching it
and what was it like working with keeper
well shutting down the entire blocks in
los angeles and downtown
uh is exciting it's it's on a scale
it's pretty grand um and you know
keeper was one of the reasons i became
an actor
so getting to come full circle and work
with one of your heroes
is um it's a very humbling experience
it's a very exciting experience it's a
very
comforting experience because you know
that you're in really good hands with
who you're working with
and you know you're giving that workload
and it's a great responsibility to have
to
try to meet his bar i'm not going back
to prison again for something i didn't
do
kiefer i read that you said this is one
of the best scripts that you've read in
the past 10 years so what is it about
this story and these characters that you
fell in love with
mike farrow is our one and only suspect
in this morning's bombing
he is currently at large and armed i
thought it was witty
i thought it was funny i thought it was
dynamic i thought it was dramatic
it had so many qualities but it also
moved at a pace
now the real danger is when you read
something like that it doesn't always
transfer when you go
to put it on its feet but this really
did it was
it was one of the
the easiest uh jobs i've ever had
just because the script was such a
strong foundation
it was an absolute pleasure to be a part
of